we also have tik-tok falling into the
middle of this i want to unpack
tick-tock just for a moment
it's owned by a company that is a
chinese company
it there in my experience any system
any data that can be hacked will be
hacked all data all information
eventually attacked
any information controlled by a chinese
or any other authoritarian country
has the keys to the kingdom in my mind
there is
zero chance that the ccp does not have
complete access
or you know whatever level of access
they want to that data because
all the [ __ ] companies in china
are required to give that level of
access already
so why wouldn't one operating the united
states also have that level of access
what do you think about my assessment of
the situation as somebody who's not on
the ground in china but
is involved in technology and you know
used to manage servers for a living when
i was in the i.t world
i think it's an accurate assessment
assessment i think
tick-tock is precedent setting and it's
really important we get it right
the way i see it there are three main
issues in this case that need to be
unpacked
the first is whether the president has
the authority to
force a divestment or suspend
transactions with an entity
on grounds of national security the
second is whether or not the president
followed an adequate process
for deliberating and implementing the
action and the third
is whether or not the outcome is the
right outcome or is at least justified
on the first the presidents have fairly
commonly
put sanctions on entities like banks in
the past
i suspect this case feels different to
some people in the public because
tick-tock is a consumer mobile
application
but based on my understanding of the
authorities granted by
the defense production act of 1950 the
foreign investment
risk review modernization act of 2018
and the international emergency economic
powers act
i do believe that the president has the
authority to take
both types of actions with that said
unlike in china we have a system that's
based on dually past
laws and checks and balances and in our
system
tiktok has the ability to sue the
actions that the white house has taken
if it believes that they are unlawful in
part or in whole
congress can choose to amend the law if
it believes that the law should be
clarified in some way
though once the case is thoroughly
litigated
the question is whether a majority of
two-thirds of the senate
will conclude that the law was applied
in an unintended way
and i i think like you i actually think
most members of congress will simply
view this
as the law working as intended and that
future presidents regardless of what
party
should have the authority to take
similar actions against
applications that pose similar national
cyber security risks
and when you look at the public's
naivete to this they think it's just a
dance app
but it's part of the problem that people
are so unsophisticated when they think
about
their smartphone that they don't also
realize that it has a
microphone camera gps and your photo
albums
and can be rooted and your mac address
can be hacked as
a as apparently tick tock has been doing
and that even if the data this was the
stupidest thing ever saw
was the new york times i believe saying
like well the data is stored in the
united states it's like well hey dummy
you there's a thing called downloading
you download the data anytime you want
and back it up
so you have this incredibly naive group
of journalists or content producers in
the world and then you have the public
i'm not saying all journalists are but a
large number of them are when it comes
to technology issues like this
and the public is it's wrapped in a
silly dance moves
but we had specifically um
i believe it was isis or al qaeda or
some derivative
group that was actually tracking our uh
soldiers and and high target soldiers
like seals and green berets
in the united states and overseas
because of their smartphones and that
became a very critical issue of hey like
you guys can't be on social media and we
had to come up with policies for that
because they were
looking to assassinate our high value
generals
and special forces so this is not some
abstraction this is just completely
naive attain on the part of
both journalists and the public yeah as
you point out
uh tick tock seems benign because it is
a video based
dance app if you look at the details of
the software
it's actually an incredibly
sophisticated
data collection software that collects
people's gps data
every 30 seconds it uh pings
your clipboard and collects what people
are copying and pasting on their cell
phones
uh on and off the app um on in an
ongoing way that might mean that tick
tock might have the passwords
to almost all your accounts including
your email um
wow so if somebody goes to their like
whatever password manager
can does the copy and then paste it and
they have access to the clipboard
boom now they have compromised some
child's account
whose parents might be a president or a
governor or the c
the ceo they could also get compromising
photos or video
this is not an abstract concept here
this is how compromat
this is how the united states the
moussade the kgb
this is how everybody's done it forever
except they used wiretaps and they used
cameras and
agents and now we basically have an app
to do it
they could and let's remember that a few
years ago they hacked the office of
personnel management so they have a list
of all the government employees that
have security clearance
so if they wanted to know who to target
in order to get
compromising information they actually
have the list of that
as of the early 2010s wow
and so this is like we're sitting here
having this conversation it seems so
obvious to us
how much of this not being clear to
our politicians has to do with the fact
that we have such a
polarized political space here you know
one of the most surprising things uh in
the current debate about tick tock
is um there is the fact that
uh the current debate seems to not
factor in
the full aperture of the reasons why i
think
the current status quo was tick-tock
doesn't make sense on the one hand
and on the other hand there is this
bizarre argument
that is being peddled that
taking action against tick-tock is
somehow replicating china's behavior
on the first point i would just say that
there are
as i see it three reasons why the u.s
taking action against tick-tock makes
sense
for the united states the first is that
as i mentioned earlier
china has taken action against almost
every
single american content platform and
given that
china's internet censorship
discriminates against foreign companies
blocks the legitimate flow of services
and doesn't offer
a channel to appeal there is a credible
argument to be made that their firewall
violates several wto
rules that china itself agreed to when
it joined the wto back in 2001.
so after years of diplomatic patience i
don't think most americans would find it
unreasonable for the us
government to demand and enforce a basic
principle of trade reciprocity
that's not arbitrary on the contrary it
would be consistent with the spirit
of wto rules and the rules-based order
that the united states
has worked so hard to build over the
last 70 years
yeah that seems to be like a no-brainer
like if you want to have tick-tock here
that's totally fine twitter
facebook instagram we're all coming to
china
the chances of that happening are
exactly zero right xi jinping would
never allow
any of those platforms in correct it
would never it would never happen
if we asked for a reciproc reciprocity
it would not happen it's just not a
possibility